quoi
tu sens ça
et vous êtes
isaac
salle pas fin à leurs visages pouvez
vous nous en dire plus sur cette
aventure
mais tout a une minute je suis un autre
cas contraire ce truc arrive
[Musique]
ça va avec tu crois que ce pas à temps
mais tu étais où ces derniers jours by
her way he et le jour d'avant j'ai
absolument rentrer sam est vraiment
arrivé ça fait trois jours qu'on t'a pas
vu ils à vivre
avez vous rencontré
un extraterrestre isaac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
qu est-ce qu ensemble quand les gens
disent que vous êtes un imposteur
[Musique]
bonjour il ya dieu
mais nous avons détenu contre votre
volonté parce que nous console je vous
avez des informations qui pourrait être
précieuse pour l'avenir de notre société
il nous tient de plus
quand il ay voir on aura qu'une seule
chance
tu crois qu'on a été exposé à quelque
chose qui aurait pu nous changer
on nettoie pour continuer à rester
modeste beaucoup trop d'un jeu de combat
prévention a été trop aux rives de la
mer copines ça
[Musique]
pourquoi vous nous avez relevé